seriously spoilers the most recent
episode of Doctor Who if you haven't
seen it go away all right so let's talk
about Joe Martin's character of the
doctor question mark I'll probably end
up referring to her as Ruth I suppose we
could call a doctor no I can't I can't
call a doctor Ruth oh my god I just
realized that no that doesn't work uh
Ruth let's go with that because I need
to distinguish her from everybody from
everything else so I'm gonna do a little
bit here like what I did with the master
a little while ago talking about where
does this master fit in one of the
options what do I think so kind of the
same deal here this is uh this is a much
bigger monkey wrench and in some ways
it's a lot I think potentially easier to
figure out what's going on or at least
easier to make some definitive things
well it can't be this because as I said
when I did the video on the master there
are huge swathes of the Masters history
that we just don't know and we haven't
seen actually most of the regenerations
regenerations my god regenerations of
the Masters so we don't have a clear
through line that we can follow with the
doctor it's not the same case so Ruth
revealed as the doctor has the TARDIS
TARDIS looks like a phone box is not
making use of a sonic screwdriver and so
between these factors lots of people are
floating lots of ideas and I'm gonna go
over some of them I have notes this time
and so we're gonna go over some of the
things that I've seen floated and why I
think some of those are more or less
likely than others let's start with one
that I keep seeing popping up that is
the ID
gyah that this doctor actually predates
any doctor we've seen before
meaning this doctor earlier then
Hartnell currently known as the first
doctor
I've seen this floated in a number of
places and I think maybe the fact that
she didn't really seem to recognize the
sonic screwdriver or at least she didn't
take it seriously I I personally didn't
read it as not realizing what it was
just more about why do you need that and
the doctor has gone without it that more
than a few occasions but I think that
might have been part of the reason and
also like people still latch onto that
line that Missy had I knew the doctor
back when he was a little girl as if it
was true like we have absolutely no
reason to believe that that was true in
fact it's called into question and even
immediately after she says it like what
I don't know why people latch on tonight
anyways I don't think this one is even a
possibility here's why the main reason
is the TARDIS the TARDIS is already the
phone box
the reason the TARDIS is the phone box
is because the doctor William Hartnell's
doctor landed in 1963 London which is
where it became a foam box for the first
time and then the then the chameleon
circuit got broke and it got stuck it
would have no reason to ever appear as a
phone box at any point prior to them him
landing with Susan in London in the 60s
no reason whatsoever so if this is a
doctor pre Hartnell why does the TARDIS
look like that or for that matter why
does she have a TARDIS at all now it's
not impossible for the doctor at an
earlier point from when he stole the
TARDIS to have had you sub one in some
way but it seems iffy at best and also
there's the regeneration issue because
we have every single regeneration
covered and it was reasserted it was
originally established in classic who
and then it got real
in time of the doctor that every doctor
gets 13 goes
so that was one two three four five six
seven eight
war doctor that brings us up to nine and
so ninth doctor actually brings us up to
ten tenth doctor counts for two because
he burned off her generation when he
caused the meta-crisis doctor and so
that brings us up to 12 which made
eleven Matt Smith the final regeneration
and he was until the time lords granted
him a new regeneration a new
regeneration set in time of the doctor
now
the fact that the time lords were able
to do that does mean there is some
bending to be had here but it just
doesn't track with the doctor in terms
of his progression as a character as an
adventurer to have had a whole ton of
offworld adventures prior to heart know
grabbing his granddaughter and a TARDIS
and bolting it just doesn't really track
for me on a lot of levels on a character
level on a logistical level I don't
think this one's very likely at all and
I think going that way would be very
very messy so let's go with I think one
of the more intriguing possibilities so
I got to think I got to come up with a
quick way to sum this up because it
involves a whole other subset of things
that like I would need a whole other
video to explain so there is a fan
theory that is referred to as season 6b
and this has to do with what happened to
the second doctor after the end of the
war games because if we want to get
super technical about it the
regeneration of the second doctor into
the third doctor is the only one that we
didn't actually see happen because if
you don't know your classic who super
well at the end of the war games the
second doctor he was going to have a
regeneration forced by the Time Lord
and Patrick Troughton kind of falls back
into darkness and but we don't see the
regeneration he just stumbles out of the
TARDIS as Jon Pertwee at the start of
the next season
now season six be basically postulates
that the between the dime Lords taking
the doctor and them actually may
actually executing his sentence of
forced regeneration that there was a gap
in there during which the second doctor
actually worked for the Time Lords
basically in an effort to stall his
sentence for as long as he possibly
could this is actually backed up by some
official license stuff but not
definitively by any of the shows it's
stuff that's been affirmed in comics
novels I think there might have been an
audio or two that kind of fit into this
the only thing that feels like it at all
fits into it is the episode the two
doctors in which Patrick Troughton and
his companion Jaime appeared and the and
it's not referenced explicitly that this
is what's going on in that episode but
as part of the fan theory and it's about
the one piece of in show evidence cuz it
would account for the fact why the
doctor Jaime look older then they should
and why the doctor is working for the
Time Lords when he's frigging terrified
of them so if we go with the theory of
there being a season six B if we take
that on board an ish aliy that would
actually fit a couple of things because
if we accept that as a reality that's
actually a whole ton of time that a lot
of things could happened including
regenerations that maybe weren't the
forced regeneration that the Time Lords
were planning maybe something just
happened in the doctor I had to
regenerate it would explain why the
doctor is like claims to have worked for
gat this other Gallifreyan that would
explain that connection we do still run
into the issue of the limitation of the
number of regenerations but
this occurred during a time when the
doctor was working directly with the
Time Lords they might have had ways of
basically having this knock count
because as we know they can grant whole
new regeneration cycles so they may have
had ways of basically granting this
little extra go because the doctor was
working for them and then if we
extrapolate this theory if Ruth is the
doctor having run away they take the
doctor back and then just execute the
sentence and stick him into his into his
third regeneration so that's not a bad
theory I'm not sure how likely it is
because the that's kind of a deep cut
lore wise especially because it leans
really heavily on classic while new era
who is very quick to borrow things like
monsters and whatnot from classic era
Doctor Who they don't do a ton of deep
lore dives because they know a lot of
people who watch the modern era doctor
who don't watch classic era Doctor Who
or they haven't watched all of it and
don't know it as well as they know the
new stuff that's actually the case with
me I'm still working my way through a
lot of classic stuff so I think for that
reason they'd be remiss to dig into
something as and that's as much of a
deep cut as season 6b is that said
possible so other than that I I think
the main thing to establish and this
seems very clear to me between the fact
that neither doctor recognizes the other
and Gatz reaction being this shouldn't
be happening something is going wrong I
feel like that was a very deliberate
plant that something is wrong this is
not just normal course of events now and
like the whole way it feels is that it's
more than just the doctors memory is
wonky like something is wrong with time
that's the sense that I get I've seen
some people thought the possibility that
this isn't actually the doctor and it's
just someone who
has the same mantle or took the mantle
I've seen some people even float that
it's Susan I don't think any of that
tracks and I think that's why that was
very deliberate in that episode where
they started saying their lines together
that they're like same brain it was to
establish as quickly as they could that
this is the same doctor this is the same
person we're not dealing with someone
else who's just saying it so I think
that needs to not even really be on the
table so as far as what and this is kind
of what I talked about in the episode
itself I think we're dealing with some
sort of split timeline or alternate
universe sort of sort of deal and
there's a number of ways that that might
end up manifesting and also I kind of
want to point out I feel like this
series is kind of leaning that way
already I mean we had the kiss avens the
savings eye whatever they were in spy
fall which came from another place in
time we seem to have already planted the
idea of things going on outside of the
normal course of time and space so if
we're already dealing with that sort of
thing would it be that big of a leap
that this is some kind of doctor who is
from an alternate dimension a parallel
universe or that something happened
whether it was when Capaldi regenerated
or could have even been before that it
could have been honestly when Smith
regenerated into Capaldi because that
was the big anomalous one that was huge
energy because it was something that
doesn't normally happen could that have
resulted in a split in another version
of the doctor also regenerating just at
a different time the one sort of hiccup
in my notion that that might be the case
is where'd she get her own TARDIS if
that's the case which would lean it a
bit more towards alternate dimension
alternate reality sort of thing because
she's got to pick up her own TARDIS from
somewhere and if it is just a split on a
regeneration well the doctor we know has
the TARDIS so where'd she get one that
said there also I also feel like I
should mention the possibility I don't
think I believe it
I'll throw it out there I mentioned the
meta-crisis doctor earlier so that is
the duplicate of David Tennant that was
created in journey's end that is on the
parallel dimension and Pete's world with
Rose and what was established was he
only had one heart he's half human he
will age he will die he won't regenerate
so they say that but what if he found a
way to be able to regenerate what if he
figured out some way to get that working
again and this is a later regeneration
off of the meta-crisis doctor I'm not
sure that's super likely if I know the
reason then I still very firmly believe
a big part of the reason they created
the meta-crisis doctor at all is to be
able at a later date bring back David
Tennant and account for the fact that
he's aged so much they'll bring back the
meta-crisis doctor because they was
established that one's gonna age so
until they pay off that I don't see them
doing anything like he ends up getting
his own regenerations but I want to
throw that out there at least as a as a
notion as a possibility
um I've complained about this being a
possibility before there's there's the
issue of the Cartmell master plan which
is another thing that I would have to
devote a whole video to but I just don't
wanna this was something that was the
groundwork was being laid for at the
tail end of the seventh doctor of tail
end of Sylvester McCoy Sara before
classic doctor who went on it's very
lengthy hiatus this idea that the doctor
was what is known as the other because
the beginning of the Time Lords
basically existing not Gallifrey UNS
they just live on the planet but like of
Time Lord Society of them having the
ability to manipulate time came down to
Rassilon and Omega but there was going
to be introduced this idea that there
was a third there was an other and it
was part of the plan to have that
eventually be revealed to be the doctor
now I always hated this idea I always
thought it was terrible and I'm really
glad it never got executed on but
I wouldn't put it past them to at least
have it in the mix as a possibility that
this version of the doctor whatever she
is somehow ties into that because like I
said maybe that's too much of a deep cut
of classic who lore but it's also the
kind of thing that given that Rassilon
has already been reintroduced we're
still waiting on Omega they'll get
around to it eventually
they'd better but I don't think the
concept of the other is as hard a thing
to explain it's not as it's not as
continuity nitpicky as something like
season 6b I don't want that to be the
case but I just kind of felt that he to
toss it out there and also like I do
have to wonder if this is related to
this new master because we did have the
question where the new master come from
now like I said when I did that video
there's a lot more possibilities that we
can look at with that because we have
all these gaps in the Masters timeline
that we don't have with the doctors
timeline at least in terms of where
regenerations occurred I mean there's a
lot of gaps in the doctors timeline but
regeneration is pretty well tracked and
because of that you know when I did my
video talking about where does the
master fit in I do have to now wonder if
we are dealing with some sort of split
time or alternate universe or other
dimension or what have you is that where
this master came from also which would
be a way to sort of skirt around
answering the issue of where in the
regeneration is does he come from does
he follow on from Missy cuz no one's
supposed to be able to so that I
wouldn't be shocked to find out that
these these two are kind of linked and I
expect them facing off against each
other to be part of the finale the
finales gonna have a lot of stuff to
cover because it's gonna have that most
likely still needing to be wrapped up
plus whatever the heck the lone Cyberman
is plus jack has to come back
yes that must happen but the new doctor
possibly or an alternate doctor whatever
it is that's going on
what do you think what are your thoughts
on this whatever they are drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
if you wish to support me I have a
patreon of course I also have a PayPal
tip jar and even if you are not able to
help me out in that way which I
immensely appreciate they're still like
subscribe
those help a lot social media links for
all that stuff's down below but you also
don't have to because end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]